Jake:你先把它开起来
Jake: First, turn it on.
Jake:然后放到窗边
Jake: Then put it by the window.
Jake:就是先把那个开起来
Jake: Yeah, just turn that on first.
Jake:然后对齐一下时间
Jake: Then sync the time.
Tasha: 哦行
Tasha: Oh, got it.
Alice:就我不用带是吧不用带
Alice: So I don't have to bring it, right?
Jake:你就放那
Jake: Just leave it there.
Alice:开了吗
Alice: Is it on?
Jake:给你找个机位
Jake: Let me find a spot for you.
Alice:天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Tasha: 天呐下次
Tasha: Oh my god, next time.
Tasha: 像是观摩一位名牌化妆师的
Tasha: It feels like watching a famous makeup artist.
Alice:我还害怕说实话
Alice: Honestly, I'm a bit scared.
Tasha: 的感觉可是我只是一个垃圾
Tasha: But I'm just a nobody.
Tasha: 好那我就要用出我的12分功力了
Tasha: Alright, I'll give it my all.
Alice:我会我会努力化的
Alice: I'll try my best with the makeup.
Jake:看到了你自己
Jake: Did you see yourself?
Alice:啊不对还没开始
Alice: Ah, no, we haven't started yet.
Jake:对连一下
Jake: Yeah, connect it.
Tasha: 怎么你也要看
Tasha: What, you want to watch too?
Lucia: 他看热闹
Lucia: He's just here for the fun.
Jake:我我可以插根线
Jake: I, I can plug in a cable.
Alice:1240吗
Alice: Is it 1240?
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Tasha: 垃圾
Tasha: Trash.
Alice:1240你们俩已经开始了吗
Alice: 1240, have you two already started?
Tasha: 嗯开始了
Tasha: Yeah, we started.
Alice:那我就1240吧
Alice: Then I'll go with 1240.
Alice:我们来一个第一人称的
Alice: Let's do a first-person view.
Alice:这样ASM哈哈哈
Alice: Like this, ASM hahaha.
Alice:欢迎来到
Alice: Welcome to...
Alice:星星的
Alice: ...the star's...
Alice:  呃呃直播化妆空间
Alice: ...uh, live makeup space.
Tasha: 喜欢听AMSR吗
Tasha: Do you like listening to ASMR?
Alice:我我每天都要听
Alice: I, I listen every day.
Tasha: 你每天都要听我也听
Tasha: You listen every day? I do too.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mm.
Jake:开了吗别别别早了早了
Jake: Is it on? No, no, too early, too early.
Tasha:开了
Tasha: It's on.
Alice:我们都开了
Alice: We're all set.
Jake:这个啊头发挡住了
Jake: Hey, the hair is blocking it.
Lucia: 这很真实
Lucia: That's so real.
Lucia: 就是我们人类的头发也经常会打碎
Lucia: I mean, our human hair often gets in the way too.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:对对确实确实真实
Jake: Yeah, yeah, that's true.
Jake:难度太高它搞不动
Jake: The difficulty is too high, it can't handle it.
Alice:这是歌剧魅影吗
Alice: Is this Phantom of the Opera?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:好用吗
Alice: Is it good?
Alice:好用我也买一个算了我不会遮瑕
Alice: If it's good, I'll buy one too. I can't do concealer.
Tasha: 我嗯
Tasha: I, um...
Tasha: 我的建议是
Tasha: My suggestion is...
Alice:我自己来吧
Alice: I'll just do it myself.
Tasha: 什么你自己来我先
Tasha: What do you mean you'll do it yourself? Let me...
Lucia: 我觉得等我回家
Lucia: I think when I get home...
Lucia: 我也得买一个这种大一点的化妆包
Lucia: I need to buy a bigger makeup bag like this.
Lucia: 我每次东西都放不下
Lucia: I can never fit all my stuff.
Tasha: 好那我们第一步
Tasha: Alright, so the first step...
Alice:遮瑕
Alice: Concealer.
Tasha: 啊没有什么瑕算了
Tasha: Ah, there's nothing to conceal, forget it.
Jake: 第二步
Jake: Second step.
Lucia: 校准一下时间
Lucia: Adjust the time.
Jake: 对第二部校准一下
Jake: Yes, the second step, adjust it.
Alice:给他看这个
Alice: Show him this.
Tasha: 好这个
Tasha: Okay, this one.
Alice:我自己涂开吧嗯
Alice: I'll apply it myself, okay.
Lucia: 哎我又把我手机撂哪去了
Lucia: Oh, where did I leave my phone again?
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:素人改造计划启动
Alice: Let's start the makeover plan.
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Alice:我一想到这是个摄像头
Alice: When I think about the camera...
Alice:我现在有点难受
Alice: I feel a bit uncomfortable.
Alice:有点不好意思
Alice: A bit embarrassed.
Tasha: 感觉这化妆刷也不是很好用
Tasha: I feel like this makeup brush isn't that great.
Tasha: 为什么卖十几块钱一个
Tasha: Why is it sold for over ten bucks?
Alice:就这样直接粉底得了哎
Alice: Just go straight to the foundation, ugh.
Alice:我也用了这个UKISS的这个这个 对
Alice: I also used this UKISS one, yeah.
Tasha: 打底
Tasha: The base.
Alice:哦我懂了这个叫嗯什么提亮暗沉
Alice: Oh, I get it, this is for brightening dull areas.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Alice:只要手揉开就行了吧啊
Alice: Just need to knead it open with your hands, right?
Tasha: 啊不不不
Tasha: Ah no no no
Alice:哦这个是拇指
Alice: Oh, this is the thumb
Alice:套是吧
Alice: It's a sleeve, right?
Alice:让外国人研究一下中国的
Alice: Let foreigners study China's...
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake: 挺好挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good
Jake: 满分数据我去
Jake: Perfect score, wow
Alice:哇其他几个是啥来着
Alice: Wow, what are the other ones again?
Tasha: 哦你稍微转过来一些
Tasha: Oh, just turn around a bit
Alice:其他几个是啥来着我也不记得
Alice: What are the other ones again? I don't remember
Jake: 这是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 给你增加一些
Lucia: Add a little more for you
Lucia: 人类早期绘制猫咪的珍贵场面
Lucia: A precious scene of early humans drawing cats
Jake: 哦临摹是吗
Jake: Oh, copying, right?
Lucia: 哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahaha, yes
Jake: 现在在
Jake: Now it's...
Alice:这 叫面中提亮吗
Alice: This is called highlighting in the middle of the face, right?
Alice:是吗
Alice: Right?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Jake: 我去
Jake: Wow
Tasha: 是
Tasha: Yes
Alice:我懂但我不会
Alice: I understand, but I can't do it
Jake: 有点专业的
Jake: It's a bit professional
Tasha: 你有点专业在身上呢
Tasha: You have a bit of professional skill in you
Alice:但是我直接就第一步上粉底然后没了
Alice: But I just put on foundation in the first step and that's it
Tasha: 但是我今天也没遮瑕
Tasha: But I didn't use concealer today either
Alice:我觉得太麻烦了直接上个粉底就完事了
Alice: I think it's too troublesome, just putting on foundation is enough
Tasha: 你的鼻子有一点点塌
Tasha: Your nose is a bit flat
Alice:鼻子有一点点塌
Alice: My nose is a bit flat
Alice:我去度一下吧
Alice: I'll try to fix it
Alice:那都不必了
Alice: That won't be necessary
Tasha: 但是我也不知道怎么把他画的很挺
Tasha: But I don't know how to make it look high
Jake: 好多笔啊
Jake: So many pens
Alice:我会一点点
Alice: I know a little bit
Jake: 我也在找笔
Jake: I'm also looking for a pen
Tasha: 找什么笔
Tasha: What pen are you looking for?
Jake: 你能写什么笔
Jake: What pen can you write with?
Lucia: 哎刚才才那个那支笔
Lucia: Hey, where's that pen from just now?
Lucia: 那个咱们用来写那个啥的画
Lucia: The one we used to draw that thing.
Jake: 是我自己
Jake: It's mine.
Jake: 有一只给我扔哪去了
Jake: I threw one somewhere.
Alice:去哪了
Alice: Where did it go?
Tasha: 嗯应该是没关系没什么可
Tasha: Hmm, it shouldn't matter. It's no big deal.
Lucia: 不对我把这个爪子画太长了
Lucia: No, I drew this claw too long.
Alice:可以到粉底了吗
Alice: Can we move on to foundation?
Tasha: 可以了吧
Tasha: I think so.
Alice:你这是干皮的还是油皮的
Alice: Is your skin dry or oily?
Tasha: 干皮的没事
Tasha: It's dry, no problem.
Alice:无所谓就这样
Alice: It doesn't matter, just do it like this.
Alice:你是干皮吗
Alice: Is your skin dry?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Alice:不过我现在也像干皮了
Alice: But my skin feels dry now too.
Tasha: 完了
Tasha: Oh no.
Tasha: 感觉我帮你画的不好看
Tasha: I feel like I didn't do a good job with your makeup.
Alice:没关系你不画也不好看
Alice: It's okay, it wouldn't look good even if you didn't do it.
Alice:我自己拍吧
Alice: I'll apply it myself.
Alice:是不没涂匀
Alice: Isn't it not applied evenly?
Tasha: 还算匀吧
Tasha: It's pretty even, I guess.
Tasha: 鼻翼这再
Tasha: The nose wings need more.
Tasha:行
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Good.
Alice:每次都差不多用手把它
Alice: Every time, I just use my hands to...
Tasha: 我的妈
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Lucia: 哈对不起
Lucia: Haha, sorry.
Alice:就是涂的基本上就那啥
Alice: Basically, just apply it like this.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 他有那个什么吗
Lucia: Does it have that thing?
Alice:之后就稍微
Alice: Then just a little bit more.
Jake: 这这这
Jake: This, this, this.
Tasha: 感觉挤太多了
Tasha: Feels like too much.
Lucia: 啊啊sorry sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry, sorry.
Alice:你来点
Alice: You add some.
Jake: 没事
Jake: No problem.
Tasha: 哦我不了
Tasha: Oh, I won't.
Lucia: 要命
Lucia: Oh dear.
Lucia: 我今天已经掉了第二次充电宝了
Lucia: I dropped my power bank for the second time today.
Tasha: 是挤的有点多
Tasha: You did squeeze a bit much.
Jake: 没关系劲摔
Jake: It's okay, just throw it hard.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Alice:抹脖子
Alice: Apply it on the neck.
Jake: 抹脖子
Jake: Apply it on the neck.
Alice:给她抹点
Alice: Apply a bit on her.
Tasha: 杨老师要来点吗
Tasha: Jake, do you want some?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake: 我哈哈哈
Jake: I... hahaha.
Jake: 啊抹哪
Jake: Where should I apply it?
Lucia: 是化点妆吗
Lucia: Are we putting on makeup?
Alice:抹脸上
Alice: Put it on your face.
Lucia: 要哈哈
Lucia: Okay, haha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake: 这化妆
Jake: This makeup...
Tasha: 眼镜摘下来吧
Tasha: Take off your glasses.
Lucia: 这个这个充电宝稍微有点大
Lucia: This power bank is a bit big.
Jake: 这么专业的
Jake: So professional.
Lucia: 我口袋里放不下
Lucia: It won't fit in my pocket.
Jake: 要不放椅子上啊
Jake: Maybe put it on the chair?
Tasha: 啊粉扑帮您扑开
Tasha: Ah, let me use the puff to spread it.
Lucia: 我可以把他用腿压住
Lucia: I can hold it between my legs.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Tasha: 然后说不要动
Tasha: Then say, don't move.
Tasha: 好美呀好美
Tasha: So beautiful, so beautiful.
Tasha: 不要动不要眨眼睛哈哈
Tasha: Don't move, don't blink, haha.
Alice: 我总感觉没弄匀就这样还有点
Alice: I feel like it's not evenly spread, there's still some left.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 杨老师你那胡子是不是该刮了
Tasha: Jake, don't you think it's time to shave your beard?
Jake: 嗯确实
Jake: Hmm, indeed.
Alice:抹匀了吗
Alice: Is it even now?
Alice:匀了吧
Alice: Even, right?
Alice:美呀
Alice: Beautiful.
Tasha: 太美了杨老师
Tasha: So beautiful, Jake.
Alice: 太美了
Alice: So beautiful.
Jake: 是啊太美了
Jake: Yes, so beautiful.
Tasha: 太美了
Tasha: So beautiful.
Alice:太美了
Alice: So beautiful.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thank you.
Tasha: 直接白了3个多
Tasha: Instantly three shades lighter.
Tasha: 您看一看
Tasha: Take a look.
Jake: 我看一看
Jake: Let me take a look.
Jake: 哈哈哈我去
Jake: Hahaha, oh my gosh.
Jake: 确实
Jake: For sure.
Lucia: 我看看
Lucia: Let me see.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 啊太美了
Lucia: Oh, it's so beautiful.
Lucia: 哈哈哈肤质一下就变得特别好
Lucia: Hahaha, my skin looks so much better instantly.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 不是不是以前也很好
Lucia: No, no, it was great before too.
Lucia: 就是更好了
Lucia: It just got better.
Jake: 这么回事可以
Jake: So that's how it is, okay.
Alice:匀了吧
Alice: Even it out?
Tasha: 明了就这吧
Tasha: Yeah, let's go with this.
Alice:就这吧下一步是睫毛
Alice: Alright, next is the eyelashes.
Jake: 就是这就是什么
Jake: So this is what?
Jake: 磨皮吗
Jake: Smoothing it out?
Tasha: 睫毛了已经
Tasha: Eyelashes are done.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Tasha: 腮红吧
Tasha: Blush next?
Alice:最后再腮红吧
Alice: Let's do blush last.
Alice:直接睫毛
Alice: Go straight to eyelashes.
Tasha: 啊啊行
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Alice:我们是不是用了同款
Alice: Are we using the same one?
Alice:v什么d什么安啊
Alice: What's it called, V something, D something?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:我用了红色
Alice: I'm using the red one.
Alice:好就这样贴
Alice: Okay, just stick it on.
Alice:夹吧我来夹吧
Alice: Curl it, I'll curl it.
Lucia: 擦了一下之后好不对称
Lucia: After wiping it, it's so asymmetrical.
Tasha: 你要贴假睫毛吗
Tasha: Are you going to put on false eyelashes?
Alice:贴
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 好你要用我的吗
Tasha: Do you want to use mine?
Alice:我的假睫毛我不一定会用你
Alice: I have my own false eyelashes, I might not use yours.
Jake: 我们是不是有买笔这个环节
Jake: Do we have that segment where we buy pens?
Alice:这是一条的吗
Alice: Is this a whole segment?
Jake: 买这个白板笔
Jake: Buying the whiteboard markers.
Lucia: 白板笔有这个环节吗
Lucia: Is there a segment for whiteboard markers?
Jake: 我怎么记得昨天有这个
Jake: I remember we had this yesterday.
Alice:没用过这个
Alice: Never used this before.
Jake: 没有就算了
Jake: If not, forget it.
Jake: 呵呵没有也可以买
Jake: Haha, even if we don't have it, we can buy it.
Tasha: 这个免胶
Tasha: This is glue-free.
Lucia: 打孔器和彩笔
Lucia: A hole puncher and colored pens.
Alice:我有胶
Alice: I have glue.
Lucia: 哎确实有
Lucia: Oh, we do have it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 但是已经有人在这里打了个勾
Lucia: But someone already made a mark here.
Tasha: 我也有叫
Tasha: I also called.
Lucia: 我不知道是不是
Lucia: I'm not sure if it's...
Jake: 好行行行
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 到底用哪个
Tasha: Which one should we use?
Alice:你挑吧
Alice: You pick.
Tasha: 那就免胶的吧
Tasha: Let's go with the glue-free one.
Alice:为什么是免胶呢
Alice: Why the glue-free one?
Alice:自己带的胶
Alice: I brought my own glue.
Tasha: 嗯它上面好像有那种胶吧
Tasha: Hmm, it seems like it has glue on it.
Alice:牢固吗
Alice: Is it secure?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我我都没拆包装呢
Tasha: I haven't even opened the package yet.
Alice:哎呀夹的不太好
Alice: Ah, it's not clamped well.
Alice:这样吧
Alice: Let's do it this way.
Alice:这样行吗
Alice: Is this okay?
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Yes.
Alice:没夹差不多
Alice: Not clamped properly.
Alice:无所谓反正会贴
Alice: It doesn't matter, it will stick anyway.
Alice:嗯等一下睫毛打底
Alice: Hmm, wait a minute, lash primer.
Alice:睫毛打底
Alice: Lash primer.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 它这个胶还可以重复使用
Tasha: This glue can be reused.
Tasha: 也不知道真的假的
Tasha: Not sure if it's true.
Tasha: 这个粘在最边边
Tasha: This sticks on the edge.
Tasha: 这个粘在中间的那种感觉
Tasha: This sticks in the middle, kind of.
Alice:先从中间开始粘
Alice: Start sticking from the middle.
Tasha: 他说不加按夹
Tasha: They said not to press and clamp.
Tasha: 曲线夹
Tasha: Curved clamp.
Tasha: 取睫毛不要碰到底部的这个胶条
Tasha: When removing the lash, don't touch the base glue strip.
Alice:从中间开始贴吧
Alice: Start sticking from the middle.
Alice:我不知道边边在哪
Alice: I don't know where the edge is.
Tasha: 我也不知道
Tasha: I don't know either.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
Tasha: 是不是从下面开始加
Tasha: Do we start from the bottom?
Tasha: 这样子对
Tasha: Like this, right?
Alice:不能从这不能碰到他
Alice: No, you can't touch it from there.
Alice:要不然我们还是用有有胶的吧
Alice: How about we use the one with glue?
Alice:不会用这个
Alice: I can't use this.
Tasha: 失败
Tasha: Failed.
Alice:我有胶
Alice: I have glue.
Tasha: 我也有胶
Tasha: I have glue too.
Alice:你用这个用这个吗
Alice: Are you using this one?
Alice:还挺好用的
Alice: It's pretty good.
Tasha: 好好
Tasha: Okay, okay.
Alice:给你推荐一下
Alice: Let me recommend it to you.
Alice:我姐姐是化妆师她就给我推荐这个
Alice: My sister is a makeup artist, she recommended this to me.
Tasha: 哦就挤在这啊
Tasha: Oh, just squeeze it here?
Alice:不是有个什么山区哦
Alice: Isn't there some mountain area?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:但我没有
Alice: But I don't have it.
Alice:但我刚看到
Alice: But I just saw it.
Alice:一次用3个吗
Alice: Do you use three at once?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 我就用了一个两个吧
Tasha: I just used one or two.
Tasha: 我说我今天没有用过
Tasha: I said I haven't used it today.
Alice:这是一个眼型哦
Alice: This is an eye shape, oh.
Tasha: oh
Tasha: Oh.
Alice:但颜色有点太长了
Alice: But the color is a bit too long.
Tasha: 有点多
Tasha: It's a bit much.
Alice:不敢想象这个粘在我的眼睛上会是一个什么样的效果
Alice: I can't imagine what it would look like stuck on my eye.
Tasha: 俏
Tasha: Cute.
Alice:这也太太太明显了
Alice: This is too, too, too obvious.
Alice:太长了
Alice: Too long.
Tasha: 好你要用你的是吗
Tasha: Okay, you want to use yours?
Alice:用我的吧
Alice: I'll use mine.
Alice:好怕hold不住他
Alice: I'm afraid I can't handle it.
Alice: 我的在哪呢
Alice: Where's mine?
Alice: 那个是我的
Alice: That one's mine.
Alice:我用这个
Alice: I'll use this one.
Tasha: 嗯这不差不多吗
Tasha: Hmm, isn't this about the same?
Alice:这个要没那么长
Alice: This one isn't as long.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:那用你的吧
Alice: Then use yours.
Tasha: 啊都可以了
Tasha: Ah, it's all fine.
Alice:真的hold不住说实话
Alice: Honestly, I can't handle this.
Alice:毕竟充满生活地
Alice: After all, it's full of life.
Tasha: 要找什么
Tasha: What are we looking for?
Jake: 笔
Jake: A pen.
Tasha: 我上楼给你拿支笔吧好
Tasha: I'll go upstairs and get you a pen, okay?
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Alice:这也太长了
Alice: This is too long.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Alice:是吧太夸张了
Alice: Right? It's too exaggerated.
Tasha: 不夸张哈哈
Tasha: Not really, haha.
Alice:不夸张这不夸张吗
Alice: Not really? Isn't it exaggerated?
Alice:我不敢想象这个出现在我的眼上
Alice: I can't imagine this on my eyes.
Alice:不夸张吗
Alice: Not exaggerated?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Alice:太夸张了
Alice: It's too exaggerated.
Tasha: 有点
Tasha: A little bit.
Alice:把它取下来吧
Alice: Take it off then.
Alice:用我的那个安回去试一下
Alice: Use mine and try putting it back.
Tasha: 还能安回去的是吗
Tasha: You can put it back on?
Alice:可以OK
Alice: Yes, it's okay.
Alice:要不然你贴一个
Alice: Or you stick one on.
Alice: 你试一下这个
Alice: Try this one.
Tasha: 今天就算了吧
Tasha: Let's skip it for today.
Alice: 胶水我搁哪
Alice: Where did I put the glue?
Tasha: 你要不还在这上面粘吧
Tasha: Why don't you stick it on here?
Alice:也行
Alice: That works.
Tasha: 好果然每个人都有自己适合的
Tasha: Yeah, everyone has their own suitable way.
Alice:你看着我玩不无聊吗我给你也来个
Alice: Isn't it boring to watch me play? Let me get you one too.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 可以好吧
Tasha: It's fine, really.
Tasha: 真的挺自然的
Tasha: It looks pretty natural.
Lucia: 吃草莓吗
Lucia: Want some strawberries?
Lucia: 姐妹们
Lucia: Ladies?
Tasha: 哈哈不是作为旁观者
Tasha: Haha, not as an observer.
Tasha: 而是开始偷偷洗草莓了开始
Tasha: But secretly started washing strawberries.
Lucia: 要吃吗
Lucia: Want some?
Alice:谢谢谢谢
Alice: Thanks, thanks.
Lucia: 我感觉我开始有点饿了
Lucia: I feel like I'm starting to get a bit hungry.
Tasha: 距离我们吃完早饭
Tasha: It's only been an hour since we finished breakfast.
Tasha: 可能就一个小时
Tasha: Probably just an hour.
Lucia: 我也属于饿的比较快那种类型的
Lucia: I'm the type that gets hungry pretty quickly.
Tasha: 嗯你贴到哪了
Tasha: Hmm, where did you stick it?
Alice:没贴哪
Alice: Nowhere yet.
Tasha: 哦贴三处是吧
Tasha: Oh, you mean stick it in three places?
Tasha: 你会贴吗
Tasha: Do you know how to stick it?
Lucia: 从来没贴过
Lucia: Never stuck it before.
Alice:你是长豆哦
Alice: Are you getting a pimple?
Tasha: 吃了
Tasha: I ate it.
Alice:应该是水珠子
Alice: It should be a water drop.
Tasha: 再贴另一个眼睛
Tasha: Stick it to the other eye.
Alice:我把胶搁哪
Alice: Where did I put the glue?
Alice:如果化一半
Alice: If you only do half...
Alice:饭来了
Alice: Food's here.
Alice: 太尴尬了
Alice: So awkward.
Lucia: 就民以食为天先吃饭
Lucia: Well, people rely on food as their primary need, let's eat first.
Alice:多挤点我也来贴一个
Alice: Squeeze out a bit more, I'm going to stick one too.
Lucia: 你以前贴过吗没有
Lucia: Have you stuck it before? No, right?
Tasha:没有
Alice:来吧来吧
Alice:跟我一起
Tasha:啊不你先贴吧
Alice:我快贴好了
Alice:嗯我贴上了下睫毛快
Tasha:好吧
Alice:你有下睫毛吗
Tasha:好
Alice:这是你的下睫毛吗
Tasha:你要吗你要贴吗
Alice:我没有贴过单块的假睫毛
Tasha:我都没拆开
Lucia: 果然没贴过
Lucia: 我饭再不来
Lucia: 我就要开始考虑
Lucia: 偷吃冰箱里昨天的肯德基了哈哈
Tasha: 吃吧吃吧
Lucia: 再等等
Lucia: 啊真奇怪
Alice:妈呀就这样吧
Alice: Oh my, let's just do it this way.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Okay?
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Alice:不要管他了
Alice: Just ignore him.
Alice:没什么耐心啊
Alice: No patience at all.
Alice:逐渐暴躁啊不要他
Alice: Gradually getting irritated, don't want him.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 还好我们几个人都不太会化妆我就安心了
Tasha: Luckily, none of us are good at makeup, so I'm relieved.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 大家都处于同样的这个起跑线上
Lucia: We're all starting on the same level.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:起跑线是差不多的
Alice: The starting line is about the same.
Lucia: 帽子好可爱
Lucia: The hat is so cute.
Lucia: 跟你的衣服颜色特别搭配
Lucia: It matches your outfit perfectly.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh dear.
Alice:睫毛弄在这上面
Alice: The eyelash is sticking here.
Lucia: 可以直接在衣服上擦的吗
Lucia: Can you wipe it directly on your clothes?
Lucia: 那个这里有纸哈哈
Lucia: There's a tissue here, haha.
Alice:逐渐暴躁
Alice: Gradually getting irritated.
Alice:有的时候就手感运气之类的
Alice: Sometimes it's just about the feel and luck.
Alice:我去真服了
Alice: Oh man, I'm really done.